من منا لا يحب السفر والبحث عن وجهات
جديده واكتشافها والخوف في مغامرات شيقه
مع رفيق السفر الا ان توجه العالمي بتميل
واسلوب السفر المنفرد والذي يشهد نمو
الملحوظا عاما بعد عام اليوم يمثل 17% من
اجماليه السفر على مستوى العالم منذر
بالنسبه لكثيرين التجربه تعني الحريه
القدره على استكشاف البلاد دون انتظار
الاخرين او ضبط مواعيدها على مواعيد
لمجموعات الكبيره يعني الرغبه في التعرف
على اشخاص جدد البعض وصفها بتجربه تسر
الروح وتساعد على الشعور
بالاستقلاليهما مخاوف الامان في العديد من
الدول وعوائق اللغه والثقافه وغيرها تمثل
النساء الاكبر يقدر ان بين 2018 و2019
سافرت اكثر من 60 الف امراه بمفردهم حول
العالم
ويقدر ان 85% من المسافرين خلال تلك
الفتره كانوا من النساء
ارتفعت شهيه السفر المنفرد بعد اسابيع من
اجراءات الاغلاق والعزله وبين ابريل 2020
وحتى نفس الفتره 2022 تضاعفت عمليات البحث
في جوجل عن السفر المنفرد باربع مرات
اظهرت بيانات من الصاد بوكينج ان 14% فقط
من المسافرين كانوا يخططون للسفر بمفردهم
قبل الجائحه وصل هذا الرقم الى
23% في منتصف 2021 وخلال نفس العام سافر
16% من الامريكيين في رحلات منفرده
ويخططون نحو 25% للسفر وحدهم خلال العام
الجاري الحال ايضا ممثل في بريطانيا حيث
يفضل اكثر من ثلث البريطانيين السفر
المنفرد وفي المانيا سافر اكثر من مليون
و400,000 شخص بمفردهم خلال عام 2000 21
وكان 30% منهم من النساء وتمثل النساء 64%
من مسافري العالم وينفقنا اكثر من الرجال
بما يعادل 15 بالمئه اثناء الرحلات من
السعوديه سالنا الناس هل تفضل السفر
بمفردك مع مرافق ولمتابع الاجابه
[موسيقى]
احب اسافر مع صحباتي اكيد
لانهم يفهمون ويعني احس انبسط معاهم اكثر
حتى اهلي بالصحباتي اكثر
مع جماعه خصوصا مع اهلي ما فيش متعه اصلا
وانا لوحدي لازم يكون معايا ناس اتكلم
معاهم كلموني استمتع بكل حاجه في التفاصيل
الرحله يعني
[موسيقى]
اسافر مع صاحباتي واسافر لوحدي بس انا
افضل اني اسافر لحالي لانه لما اسافر
لوحدي اتعرف على جنسيات جديده اتعرف على
اهل البلد نفسهم اتعرف على الثقافتهم بس
لما نسافر مع جروب او مع اصحابنا خلاص
نكون مرتبطين فيهم
همم لانه ببساطه يعني المكان ما يحلو ولا
بالناس
ممكن نروح مكان عادي جدا لكن مع ناس احبه
بس ممكن يروح مكان حلو
لوحدي ما انبسط احب اروح مع اخويا
يعني انبسط معاهم لما اروح وكده بسافر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على مواقع التواصل تجد الكثير من الشباب
والشابات الذين يقدمون محتوى خاص بالسفا
المنفرد
منهم ضيفتنا الشابه هيفاء بسيسو التي تقدم
وتشارك دائما تجاربها في مختلف في البلاد
التي تزور منذ انطلاقتها حتى اليوم
على كسر الصور النبطيه للفتاه العربيه كما
تشارك جمهورها في كثير من القضايا
الثقافيه المختلفه بدات مسيرتها في مجال
الاعلام ومن ثم انتقلت الى انشاء قناه على
يوتيوب وهذه القناه
مع هيفاء ومن خلال اصبحت تهدف الى تشجيع
الافراد لخلق تغيير في حياتها
[موسيقى]
في الفيديو تنظمي لان مدونه سفر هيفاء
بسيسو هل في يسعد صباحك نورتنا صباح
العربيه اهلا صباح الخير صباح الخير
اليوم
23 كثير باتي يحب ان يسافر بمفرده
باعتقادك لماذا
يمكن لانه كتير ناس مو شرط بدهم يستنوه
ناس ثانيين ليجمعهم برحله
وبحث كثير نعسان عندهم فضول يكتشفوا حالهم
من خلال السفر انا دايما بحكي انه بسافر
مشي بس اني اكتشف همم لا تلغي او سور
الصين العظيم بسافر لاكتشف حالي والبلدي
اللي راحه فيها فلما الواحد يسافر لحاله
بيكون فيه شوي حريه اكثر
مربوط بتجارب ومربوط بالذكريات
وصورتنا طول العمر ما بتحبي انه تشاركيها
مع حدا تقول له تتذكري لما كنا هون تتذكر
لما كنا هون مثلا هلا شيء الحلو بالموضوع
انه الواحد لما يسافر لحاله بحس بيصير
عنده كثير اصحاب فبيقدر يعمل هاي المحادثه
بنقدر نشارك هاي الذكري
طويله اخرى للشهرين بمفردك في امريكا
الوسطى زرتي مختلف الدول الم تملي يعني
كيف كانت تجربته الاول شهرين لحالك اه لا
الصراحه كل يوم مغامرات كثير كبيره كل يوم
اتعرف على ناس كثير
ولما اتعرف على ناس هناك مع بعض بنروح على
اماكن ثانيه همم بس مش بطريقه انه مش
عقلانيه او خطيره لا يعني الواحد همم يعني
بتبع حدث وببين على الواحد انا بحس حالي
دائما الله حاميني وبتعرف على ناس بتجنن
يعني مين بقعد يصورك هالانس ستوري سوريا
همم بيدخلوا بالجو معي في شات واحده
لقيتها بالبحر جنبي قلت لها معلش تساعديني
اه وبعدين لما اقول لهم انه من الانستغرام
او بلوجر كثير بتحمسوا معي ما بعرف ليش
طيب
مهم انه ما تاخذي صدقاتك بتعرفيها بس
تتعرفي على ناس هلا حلو الواحد يسافر مع
ناس بيعرفهم انا سافرت كمان واحده متسافرت
مع اهلي وعرفنا بعض بلفل ثاني مختلف تماما
يعني رحنا شيء وروحنا شيء ثاني انا السفر
بالنسبه لي هيك ومشاكل يعني
بس الباقي كله مع بعض همم بس الواحد حنان
لما يكون لحاله بيصير المجال مفتوح اكثر
للناس يحكوا معه يتقربوا لعنده همم
وانا برايي يعني ما بسافر عشان انت من
الخاص انا بسافر عشان تعمل امل ما بعتقد
انه معظم الناس
بيجننوا في شيء نتعلم ومن اي حدا بنقابله
وفعلا يعني انا مسافرات صار لي شيء سبع
سنين بسافر ما صار معي موقف خطير او حدا
ضايقني او شيء هيك طيب هيفا انت شو
اكتشفتي بذاتك من خلال السفر يعني من خلال
الايام الطويله والليالي اللي قعدتيها مع
حالك وتفكري شو حسيتي في شغله هيك ما كنت
عرفتيها عن نفسك هذا احلى سؤال على قلبي
كثير لانه دائما بحكي السفر حول العالم
والسفر للعالم الداخلي همم
السفر كثير بغير يعني كثير بيغير بالشخصيه
بالمفاهيم بعلم قد ما بيغير بده جراه
وشجاعه انه الواحد يكون عنده القابليه
يحكي باي باي للشخصيه اللي قبل اللي كان
بعرفها ما يتمسك كثير بالايجو عن وتعينيهم
فالسفا اللي اعطاني هالسفر هو
شجاعه اني احكي باي لاشياء ثانيه وافتح
مخي لاشياء ثانيه كثير كمان عشت مع
اللوكلز يعني رحت على افريقيا
الصغار والمراهقين وكيف بيحكوا مع بعض كيف
الاطفال بيحترموا الكبار
طب انا لازم اقعد معهم هاي القعده حتى لو
اتمسخروا علي انه حوالين الشجره ونمسك
الشجره مش مشكله بس فيها فائده شكرا جزيلا
لك مدونات سفر